a controversial new proposal aims to
stop overcrowding in one of the world's
most popular tourist destinations about
30 million visitors pack into the
Italian city of Venice every year
it is a beautiful city to deal with the
crowds the city is planning to start
charging many tourists an entrance fee
Seth Doane is in Venice where locals say
the city's future is at stake Seth good
morning good morning to you locals say
this place has become so busy it is like
a Disneyland for tourists this view has
always been seen as priceless but now it
in fact may come with a price upwards of
10 euros that's the u.s. equivalent of
about $11.50 per visits its famed canals
and picture-perfect setting has made
Venice infamous for its tourists hordes
pack its narrow alleys searching for
that all-important selfie but the vast
majority about four-fifths of visitors
do not spend the night so the city loses
out on potential earnings from hotel
taxes now Italy's parliament has
approved a measure that will allow the
city to charge tourists that only come
for the day could outfit but crystal
show the money would go towards keeping
the city clean Mayor Luigi Bruni o said
and allow locals to live with more
decorum Venetians have told us their
concerns the daily deluge of visitors
some coming on giant cruise ships is not
only straining the city's resources and
delicate architecture but causing Venice
to lose its soul since 1951 the city's
population has plummeted to fewer than
55 thousand people but it can see on
average more than 80 thousand visitors
per day we reported on the regular
protests from residents who have carried
suitcases as a symbol they're on their
way out we have many many too much
duties too many tourists yes
that's according to Palomar who manages
tourism for the city before the new tax
was announced she told us visitors are
essential to the economy but that the
city has reached a breaking point
tourists are our guests mark told us we
want to treat them with respect but we
want respect this is a fragile city
officials have put up gates so they can
control the flow and have proposed
raising a fine to more than $500 for
those sitting or lying on undesignated
public spaces
they've also banned the opening of new
fast-food chains out of concern Venice
was at risk of losing its identity the
tax will be higher during peak periods
that is not yet clear when or how this
fee will be implemented though it is
certain that other cities facing this
tourists crush will be watching Venice
closely Anthony it's worth it Seth still
my favorite city in the world was my
mom's favorite city in the world
unbelievable you're saying it could be
up to like 10 euros it's not all things
considered it's not a lot they should
tax those mammoths ships that come in
with those big wakes yes Seth Doane
thanks